bonjour Bruno retaillot chef de fil des
sénateurs her ici au Sénat un mot sur ce
que peut faire le Parlement ce que peut
faire le Sénat dans cette crise vous
nous l'anonz vous allez prendre une une
initiative parlementaire bien sûr je
pense que poser des questions
d'actualité c'est important pour que le
le gouvernement reste mobilisé et pour
dire notre solidarité absolue et totale
vis-à-vis d'Israël et du peuple
israélien mais on peut aller plus loin
et nous préparons avec plusieurs groupes
une résolution pour condamner les choses
et surtout les nommer et c'est je pense
que c'est le plus important aujourdi
effectivement on a vu le président du
Sénat j l'archer parler de crime contre
l'humanité par rapport à ses exactions
ces crimes terribles qu'on a vu dans les
kibouts autour de la bande de Gaza
pourquoi est-ce que c'est si important
notamment que l'exécutif et les
partenaires européens utilisent ces mots
comme c'est ce qu' a demandé la droite
sénatoriale c'est fondamental et vous
savez Gérard arché utilise toujours les
bons mots en tout cas il réfléchit quand
il s'exprime ça n'est pas un crime de
guerre crime de guerre ça voudrait dire
que on considère le Hamas comme une
armée régulière c'est c'est un groupe
terroriste ça n'est donc pas de cette
catégorie dont il s'agit il s'agit bien
d'un crime contre l'humanité qui
correspond d'ailleurs à une catégorie
juridique et qui correspond surtout à ce
qui s'est passé dans l'horreur c'est
absolument indicible puisque des enfants
des vieillards des femmes qui ont été
massacrés brûlés vif torturés et et
désormais pris en otage non non je pense
que la qualification de crime contre
l'humanité il faut pas en avoir peur il
faut l'assumer on voit que Matignon va
réunir l'Élysée pardon va réunir les
chefs de parti demain a priori au
déjeuner si si nos informations sont
correctes qu'est-ce qu'on peut attendre
politiquement de la séquence une forme
de front républicain de front commun
dans cette crise en Israël en tout cas
bien sûr qu'il faut il faut faire front
il faut que le peuple israélien sente
que la France est vraiment tout prêt à
leur côté mais il faut aussi faire plus
il faut bien vérifier dans les fonds et
die sait si la France distribue des
fonds notamment pour le peuple
palestinien mais souvent il y a la
corruption et il faudrait s'assurer que
ces fonds ne vont pas dans la poche des
terroristes donc ce que j'attends aussi
de la France c'est pas seulement des
actes politiques de communication ce que
j'attends c'est une vraie
action